أريد فقط أن أعود إلى هذا الفيديو الذي
وصلنا إليه للتو في شبكة CNN في الدقائق العديدة الماضية
فقط لتسليط الضوء على
أوضح صورة حتى الآن
لدينا حيث يمكنك رؤية البالون
مفرقعًا بشكل أساسي تم تدميره
ثم تحته مباشرة أو وأنت  يمكن أن
يرى بوضوح ما يبدو
أنه معدات المراقبة التي تسقط بسرعة
كبيرة في المحيط الأطلسي ،
ألم أكن أفترض أن ذلك يمنح
الجيش البنتاغون بعض الأمل في أن
ما يأملون في استرداده من
المحيط الأطلسي يمكن إنقاذهم وقد
يقدم بعض الأدلة بشأن  ما
كان الصينيون يصلون إليه
تمامًا أن الفيديو مذهل جدًا
ويبدو أنه يوضح
أنه ليس قريبًا إلى هذا الحد ، لكنه جيد بما فيه
الكفاية بحيث يبدو أنه يوضح أن
الصاروخ أصاب البالون نفسه على
عكس الحمولة الموجودة أسفله
حيث  الجزء المثير للاهتمام هو
معدات المراقبة ، التكنولوجيا
التي تريد الولايات المتحدة الحصول
عليها ، ويبدو أن هذا الفيديو
يظهر أن هذه الحمولة عند سقوطها كانت على
الأقل سليمة في الغالب.